please welcome Chris Miller and Philip
Lord
I know about you but I can go home now
it's a double hug double hug yeah let's
get more double directing teams that was
fun all right I'll get on that so you
guys are just starting off your journey
here and I again we're gotta set
expectations here this is really really
super early where are you guys in terms
of your your production we just moved
here two days ago
and so we're very very early we're still
working on the script with Larry and
John Kasdan and doing a lot of early
pre-production on the movie with you
know design work and that sort of thing
now you mentioned Larry and John Cavs in
Korea I I can I could just hear my head
you tell me the story best in terms of
Larry's interests in this project and
the talent attached to it yeah Larry um
you know there's no buddy on this stage
who doesn't love and respect Larry so
much for all that he's contributed to
Star Wars and I think that as the
executive producer of this particular
movie and the writer along with his son
John he he had a lot of passion for the
idea of Chris and Phil coming aboard to
direct this movie and he was quite vocal
about it in a way that Larry can be and
and really I think had a tremendous
amount of belief in them and a feeling
that that they were just the right
people to do this and and I think that
that ended up being really meaningful to
all of us as we you know went forward
and and and put the whole thing together
and made it happen now it's uh it's real
and everybody's working together it's
pretty cool I mean such an honor from
Larry quezon you're our hero from
growing up watching all of his movies
and like I went to see Grand Canyon in
the theater opening weekend that's how
big of a fan of Lawrence cuz they're
like a real Larry head yeah I was in
high school so it's a dream come true
just from just from this part alone
on dimension the rest of it so can't get
too much into what the movies about but
obviously everyone knows it's about Han
Solo so what is Han Solo now they do Oh
what does Han Solo mean to you
oh gosh uh I sort of relate to him
he's uh he's he doesn't want to do
anything that he's told when you tell
him not to do something it makes him
want to do it more he's very sarcastic
and and at the end of the day he's
unreasonably optimistic and and I think
that's why you know we fall for that guy
and why we got it so excited about
making this movie is that this kind of
dichotomy between this kind of grouchy
seemingly cynical guy with the biggest
heart in the galaxy and and to me that's
a great thing to make a movie about yeah
I mean he's a guy I mean this is a guy
who every on the playground everybody
was fighting who gets to play Han Solo
and in my family when my sisters and I
would play Star Wars as kids I was
always Han Solo my one sister was
Princess Leia and my other sister was
Princess Leia's sister Margot which is a
character we that's a good night Erin
fences yeah can work her into this this
story yeah anyway if you want to do any
less than readers my lipid extra
Skywalker um there is another other so
you like that movie the Mario Skywalker
uh but there's a guy you know he's a
maverick he's a he's a scoundrel he's
clever but he's not smart um and he's
you know he wants to present himself as
like this cool tough guy but in the idea
always does the right thing and so
that's I think that's why you love him
so much and so why he's been one of the
most iconic characters of all time yeah
yeah
now you've of course worked with Han
Solo before you've worked with the
Millennium Falcon before that is true we
did in the lego movie han Solo and
Chewbacca both appeared and the
Millennium Falcon we're all in in that
movie and as I read all of the films
with Star Wars our cannon so that means
that that is candy yeah it's gotta go
with the Lions
Batman will be appearing Batman on the
William Falcon is canon in the star wars
of these movies Batman cameo the subject
of cameos let's talk about that you guys
were this close to getting into rogue
one yes we were visiting you know doing
early prep work here and and we gun to
nogueira through this process and so he
invited us to come onto the set and
where'd you get that but we look super
deal about solid yeah we can run the
character yeah I got a bear here we go
here comes trouble
um so that's my big hard look along why
did they cut you guys no we did not
obviously never really thought about was
it that we were gonna we're gonna shoot
this thing but I you know my whole
family's moving out here for to be
living here for a year and I had to go
look at a school for my son uh we
couldn't be in Star Wars because your
son had to go to school
thanks Chris so I got all dressed up
waited around and then they're like okay
what you gonna do I was like I gotta go
I can't show up to the school interview
looking like this uh so I had to leave
I'm so bummed you didn't go like that
with the width of giant blast yeah I
don't
I feel like they would have had to let
him in oh you got so close but you know
who did actually get a cameo it's Ryan
yes that producer Rahm and I we chose
wisely we chose like the two dudes who
we knew would be in the movie they can't
cut us out because we're the two dudes
in the firing chamber the star could
pull the leathers and goat levers and go
like that and seeing seeing Rahm in that
helmet his hair just barely fit into
that helmet you may fire when ready what
we're discovering now is that cameos are
now a form of currency among our
directors uh because appearing in
Episode eight we stuck yeah we're stuck
Gareth in there we did stick everywhere
is there ever I think we have a picture
yeah look at them he's a natural natural
look at that fuzzy little guy Neil
Scanlon's team does amazing work oh do
we have another picture I don't know I
was just that okay well so I'm sure you
guys will get your shots to be in a Star
Wars movie yes are you coming out yeah
maybe in nine well maybe that kept
getting close with Colin although I
understand Chris you actually are that
wasn't your only shot you were actually
in a Star Wars movie I am in Empire
Strikes Back actually that was me Oh for
real that was a for real stormtrooper
number two and the rerelease of Empire
Strikes Back 1997 special edition I
think we have some incredibly bootleg
photos of you no not that one yes that
one's available for the public so there
I was uh I was interning at ILM 20 years
ago
and they sent her an email for 511
people to be stormtroopers and I happen
to be 511 so I got to be but they said
they were not allowed to take pictures
with your helmet off that was a
Lucasfilm policy so my friend who was
another stormtrooper and I had a little
visit before digital photography yeah
clearly I had a a little Olympus camera
film camera hidden in my lunch bag and
we like snuck around the corner and took
pictures of each other so respectful of
the so I could be fired right now I'll
have to look at the old employee
handbooks what it says about that and
the fact that you took it on film that
means you had a I can imagine you
sweating it out as you took it out to be
developed oh yeah oh so disappointed how
blurry and out of focus and washed out
they were I was like huh no one's gonna
believe me believe me right guys that's
pretty tepid I feel like some of them
don't believe you
alright we're talking about you guys can
Ewing in movies let's let's focus on the
the actual actors who are in our Star
Wars movies and and you've got a real
challenge ahead of you a character like
han Solo everyone has an impression in
their mind of what that character is
like so so what's casting what's that
process like for you guys I mean we we
thought from the very beginning this was
the hardest casting challenge of all
time I mean the biggest boots to fill
you can possibly imagine you know try to
get someone who can capture all of those
essences that you think of as Han and so
we did a very very very exhaustive
search we saw over 3,000 people for the
part um all across the world yeah right
like we casted like five or six
different offices acting schools all
across America and the UK was like
cowboy bars like everything you can
imagine trying to find someone who was
like wanted to make sure we
to find someone who had the sort of
charisma and the sort of maverick sort
of swagger and turns out that that was a
total waste of money because the person
who got the part was the first person to
audition he's literally the first person
to walk in the door Kathy I apologize
wasting that it's nice to be sure though
yes I've taken that out of your salary
okay it's fair well now that you so you
want us true you want to say who it is
hey yeah I think this is an the best
kept secret in Hollywood the intensity
of this person is Alden Ehrenreich yes
and he's actually here today what here
today so let's bring him up hi everybody
you just got you just flew in yesterday
right yeah I flew in yesterday and well
thanks so much for coming to the panel
thanks for making at the celebration did
you get any chance to look around the
show no I did probably no this is my
first taste of it yeah we're keeping you
under wraps here so maybe we'll put a
helmet on you sometime and just kind of
send you well now I told you so I can't
do that cam right there okay
next year um so what was it like I mean
as I said you were the first to audition
and then you had to wait while they
wasted the time of 2999 yeah well I went
in I went in a few times and just the
whole time I mean when it first came
along I knew kind of everybody would be
going out for it and I just I read the
sides and I loved them and I thought
alright who knows but but let me give it
a shot and then I auditioned for about
six months and I went the the coolest
part of that audition process was I went
on the Falcon and
and that is I mean kind of what you were
saying Ryan it's like it's it's it's
pretty unbelievable and and you get
there and you kind of have as a kid like
this character especially you you play
make-believe and you imagine oh and you
kind of imagine what it would be like so
when you're you get there you're like oh
yeah okay here it is you know and it's
it's pretty incredible so I'm just the
very very excited yeah
so you're screencasting aboard the
Falcon because I imagine you're trying
to see whether or not you have chemistry
with the Falcon yeah any other co-stars
that you would screen test with uh yeah
Chewbacca which is pretty incredible too
I'd never acted with the Wookiee so
that's a whole different thing which was
pretty yeah it's amazing and I had the
blaster and we did the whole kind of
costume and everything it was awesome
yeah
president fell you were telling me that
there was something particular about all
the reaction or perhaps maybe lack of
expected reaction because you thought
you watched thousands of people do that
first discovery of the Falcon and
Chewbacca and you saw a trend but oh
whoa I mean only the finalists made it
onto the actual oh I see all right
Chewbacca wouldn't have wasted money but
not that all judges but you would say
that there was a commonality in that
reaction though right yes I mean it's
not just a real experience for anybody
to like alright walk on here's the
Millennium Falcon here's like you know
here's this as the lounge's of the
cockpit and here's a seven foot three
giant talking bear man yeah and and for
everybody was like the first 20 minutes
of like trying to shoot a screen test
everyone was like are you gay we didn't
even roll camera we're just like we need
I know any system it's pretty neat
what was your quick album to not do that
do not freeze up by yeah well I mean
yeah I mean you're kind of so it's like
there's something about it that just
felt like so exciting that I think it it
that was more exciting than it was
I reckon like actually being on the
Falken after having seen it for so long
it's just yeah it's pretty you just kind
of immediately go like out right all
right cool
yeah so who have you told uh well this
is kind of where everybody's going to
find out the one person I did tell was
my mom but yeah this is this is
basically where everybody's going to
find out although people have been
coming up to me and saying
congratulations and I kind of go like
that's a good response moment what was
your mom's reaction she's pretty
thrilled it's a bit it's amazing with
this like with other roles I've gotten
people to like wow it's so exciting and
with this one she was just like what you
know like it's so so and she actually
just recently she's leaving she's moving
out of the house I grew up in and she
just found the box of my Star Wars toys
and all the Han Solo action figures I
had so she just sent me a picture of all
those yeah we have that photo do we have
those photo do we alright well we're
going here we go here is your some
people out here have that you got box
too nice I like the Tupperware then yeah
I like the setting that's very good
oh you got the previous going on here
right that's my mom's handwriting she
wants to be first camera operator on
this movie you know you know I love this
because then you got the doubly good
news of that you're in a Star Wars movie
and your mom never threw out your Star
Wars toys yeah that's right fast
you know unableto maybe very
disorganized yeah that's true alright so
where are you where are you guys in
terms of you said you guys just move to
London to start this process I mean when
are cameras going to roll on this movie
you figure um probably end of January
early February right around right around
then so we've got a good six months of
prep there's a lot of sets to design and
build and characters and robots droids
and aliens and you know crazy creatures
for Neil and his team to build so it's a
lot there's a lot of prep work that goes
into a movie like this you can't just
sort of like show up and be like oh
we'll shoot at a Starbucks
mm-hmm you know and is this your first
time working with a British crew yeah
we're really excited I mean we're using
a lot of the same crew that we're on
Ryan's movie and rogue one we're sort of
some-some from each camp and they are
the best in the business so it's going
to already tell from the people that
were working with us you know going to
be a dream working with people as
talented as this so Ryan having just
completed your principal photography or
being just that close to completing it
any words of advice after having worked
for months with with this British crew
how to keep them happy let's go settle
tea yeah give me some tea lay it on me
man
no I'm just I'm kind of envious like I'm
it did being at the end of this I kind
of wish that we could just keep filming
because it the Diana my mean you said it
it's just like the best people in the in
the business it's amazing and I'm a
really envious you guys get to it's like
you I feel like I'm coming out of a ride
and seeing you guys in line about to go
into it and my hair is standing up and
I'm like my eyes are why then like oh oh
but I'm I'm really and they're really
excited for the experience you guys are
going to have
you